je regarde regardez comme il est mignon
celui-là
oh là là comme il est trop nul
[Musique]
j'ai pas trop souffrir
vite tirer mes
trop souffrir
[Musique]
je ne sais même pas qui je suis
que je fais ce que je veux
je voudrais que dans mes derniers
de pouvoir naître entre les deux
je n'arrive pas à choisir
entre les mains et les femelles
je suis brûlé par le désir
de tailler dans la partie belle
[Musique]
et ça
comment savoir
[Musique]
sur le papier je suis un homme
je suis dans le Nord
c'est un mystère
donc je ne connais les raisons
qu'avez-vous fait de moi ma mère
bonne
et ça non
est-ce une femme
et celle-là mais une femme
comment savoir
et c'est la
[Musique]
regardez mes petites chaussures elles
sont jolies on dirait des sandales
exactement
je regarde regardez comme il est mignon
celui-là
regardez-le comme il est trop nul
attends bah alors je vais pas
assermenter
[Rires]
c'est pas un cochon là c'est un
solitaire vous savez c'est un de mes
solitaire ça c'est un sanglier regardez
même le museau bouge oui c'est vrai si
vous venez à Malo je vous verrez que il
y en a pas mal c'est pourquoi parce que
ici je vais faire au Théâtre 13 une
exposition de cochons ça vient d'où ça
vient de ça vient d'être très longtemps
on me disait que j'avais un caractère de
cochon je mangeais comme un cochon
j'étais un gros cochon donc voilà on a
commencé à m'offrir des cochons et puis
je me suis familiarisé avec les avec cet
animal qui est très très un des plus
proches de l'homme sensuel intelligent
et drôle aussi donc j'essaie de me
rapprocher de lui en fait dans ce sens
là que ça marche
est-ce que vous êtes un gros cochon oui
bien sûr
attention à mes objets celui-là il est
très beau il est africain vous l'avez vu
un très beau laurier dit non je suis un
peu handicapé parce que je n'ai qu'une
seule vue c'est par le museau par le
groin quand je le mets mais c'est un
très beau masque africain vous allez
venez suivez-moi dans les couloirs c'est
moins c'est moins chiant quand même vous
savez là c'est moins
c'est moins rouge quoi c'est moins Rouge
et Or que ce que j'ai fait sur la Seine
c'est beau la Seine regardez le bordel
voilà aïe je vais m'asseoir derrière
vous allez voir comme si comme si on
peut pas l'ouvrir vraiment je vais vous
laisser rentrer attendez regardez
poussez la porte là vous pouvez
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu